our scientists are deeply concerned
experts say a new covid variant has the
potential to be more transmissible and
evade our vaccines but what exactly is
the b11529
strain
not much is known about this new covid
variant but what we do know is enough to
worry scientists it has 35 mutations in
the crucial spike protein some of which
could make current vaccines less
effective the concern is that when you
have so many mutations that can have an
impact on how the virus behaves
it's also heavily mutated in the
specific bit of the spike that binds to
our cells
two mutations here help the delta
variant become globally dominant a new
variant has 10 mutations in this binding
domain early indications show
this variant may be more transmissible
than the delta variant
and current vaccines may be less
effective against it
it was discovered during a rapid
increase in covert cases in south africa
and scientists are concerned there is
some evidence this new surge is linked
to b11529
you can be rest assured as people start
to move even more over the next few
weeks this will be all over the uk has
already banned travel from these six
countries and people who've arrived from
there in the last 10 days are being
asked to get a pcr test i was happy to
see my family but i want to get home to
my husband and my kids now
it's a big inconvenience we had our
flights booked for a week's time
but
we got the news from our daughter in the
uk about 12 30 1 o'clock last night it's
unfair it's unjustified
it's abrupt
and it's not good for tourism for south
africa
other countries around the world have
taken similar action the european
commission has today proposed to member
states
to activate the emergency brake on
travel from countries in southern africa
and other countries affected
to limit the spread of the new variant
if the strain is more transmissible
these measures will slow the spread of
the strain but they won't contain it
the good news so far is that there are
only a handful of cases of new variant
across the globe so it looks like we
caught this one quite early the more
this virus circulates the more
opportunities the virus has to change
the more mutations we will see so we
need to drive that transmission down so
that we reduce the possibility of having
more variants emerge now the work begins
to understand whether this new variant
does have an advantage over the deadly
delta strain and our vaccines or like
many variants before it will simply die
out
but with the uk and the rest of the
northern hemisphere heading into winter
reliant on vaccines against a much older
strain it's a genuine cause for concern